we're joined on the line by
representative Dan Crenshaw represented
for Texas his second congressional
district and host of the podcast hold
these fruits he's author of the brand
new book fortitude American resilience
in the era of outrage it is available
everywhere the book is terrific Dan
great to talk to you sir and
congratulations on an excellent sparring
with that with Bill Maher the other
night very great to be with you Bennett
I appreciate it
you know I I learned my sparring from
you I wasn't gonna say well but you've
always been a better fighter now and I
just need to workout regimen because I'm
Latin as that there's video of the two
of us arm wrestling one more way yeah
dan dan engages in a sort of
compassionate end-of-life care with me
during that armwrestling session he lets
me last for a solid point seven seconds
before putting me away so Dan why don't
you a recap for our listeners what
exactly happened with Bill Maher I mean
for those who missed it Dan was on Bill
Maher show and Bill Maher basically
started with usual litany of here's all
the ways president Trump failed and he
should have acted sooner and then
basically just laid out the timeline why
you left that timeline now for folks who
missed it yeah well there's a lot to it
in this diet we have to debunk this
narrative not because it's important to
defend the president it's because it's
important to defend the truth here and
it's important to to analyze people's
decisions in the context of the fact
that they have at the time and over the
last week I've just been trying to lay
that out through my podcast through
videos we put out which the president
was very excited about he shared that
video on his own Twitter recently
there's there's a number of facts that
that we have to put into context it's
not to say that the administration has
done perfectly or that they were
perfectly prepared not the argument I'm
making I don't think it's possible to be
perfectly prepared in the face of a of a
pandemic like this I think we're all
doing the best that we can and so one
question I ask people is if you're going
to criticize these decisions or the
processes that the government is made
where where is the fork in the road
where is the decision point that you
that you think so obviously should have
been made differently you know and they
won't be able to answer that actually
they will there's one case will they'll
be able to answer that which is on
January 31st and president Trump put in
pretty draconian measures to
strict travel from China and now now
they decry that as ineffective because
people still got in well there were US
citizens and passport holders and I
point that out to them and so I asked
Bill Maher are you saying that back then
you would have actually said no US
citizens could be repatriated is that
your argument I mean I hope not because
that would be that would be that would
be pretty heartless to our to our own
citizens and so but we also know that on
that same day Nancy Pelosi and that
nobody knows this but I'm that same day
Nancy Pelosi proposed the no ban Act the
no ban Act what would that do it would
actually prevent President Trump from
from taking on those kind of measures
that he did to restrict travel so we
know for a fact that a Biden
administration or a Pelosi was in charge
they would not have done that travel
restriction that's a that's a pretty big
deal and they're trying to downplay that
in the media a lot but it's a huge deal
they also talk about the lost month of
February now this is an easy talking
point because there was no big grand
action like a travel restriction or 15
days to slow the spread that happened to
March there wasn't some big action that
took place in the February but the
question then is that all that
surprising because the reality is we
didn't have hardly any cases by March
2nd we only had 102 cases in the United
States the epithet the pandemic hadn't
really taken off in Italy or Spain yet
and they wouldn't lock down until
mid-march let's not forget that so
context is important here also it's just
not true that we weren't doing anything
in February I mean this was when
public-private partnerships were
occurring to to get vaccines done to get
testing done now none of it happened as
fast as we would like and there's in
hindsight there's plenty of things we
could have done differently like like
not have stringent FDA regulations
during a pandemic but those regulations
and long been in place and they did
prevent the private sector from creating
tests faster also it's not as if there
was a magic button that we could just
press for more PPE or less PPE the
reality is is that China has long been a
limiting their exports get a lot of it
gets manufactured there and there's a
global supply shortage so again it's
onyx making excuses
but it is explaining to people why
things are the way they are and to lay
blame at just president Trump's feats
and to say it's blood on his hands is so
over-the-top absurd and flies in the
face of the evidence that we have and
the timelines that we have so Dan
meanwhile obviously there's been a lot
of controversy that's broken out across
the country about reopening and when
Americans should reopen it seems to me
that this is broken down in the
stupidest possible way as per our usual
conversation on the one hand you have
people a very small fringe of people who
are saying well just reopen everything
no masks no social distancing just
embrace the suck just go for it man and
I think that's like seven people and I
think the media are taking those people
and blowing them way out of proportion
and then there are people who take
advantage of that on the other side then
they say well this means that as long as
there are nuts out there like this we
have to continue to lock this thing down
forever it seems like honestly the only
way out here is going to be that younger
healthier people are going to put on
masks they're going to socially distance
they're going to go back to work if you
are older if you are if you have
pre-existing conditions you're gonna
stay home you're gonna socially distance
from the younger people and eventually
that's how things are gonna be until we
come up with with better treatments or
with vaccine right and if we did away
with the political opportunism and we
just had you know I think fair-minded
people sit in a room and think in a
common-sense way about what the new
future looks like it would sound exactly
what like what you're describing every
business would have a new normal
I think mask-wearing is a new normal for
a pretty long period of time I don't
think anybody is shaking hands for a
pretty long period of time you know
there isn't it's not it's not back to
normalcy it's back to a new normal see
where we can live side by side with a
risk but also open up the economy and I
firmly believe we can do that and it's
that this shouldn't be all that
controversial but I did anticipate the
bad faith arguments I wrote about this
in an op-ed in the hill a couple weeks
ago where I noted that the real pandemic
there's two pandemics that are spreading
across America one is the bad faith of
political opportunism the other is koban
19 and that bad faith opportunism sounds
something like this well let me just ask
you a question how many lives is it
worth to save one job right and that's a
really disingenuous bad-faith way to ask
that
question you know we we we can't it's
not a binary choice of keeping everybody
shut in indefinitely and then just
letting people die like we we have to
learn how to mitigate the risk we are
doing that we're mobilizing and
transitioning to a new normal where
where we increase our testing capacity
but but most of all we engage in a sense
of personal responsibility you know it's
important to tell people like you can
prevent yourself from getting this like
there are certain measures you can take
to prevent you from from getting this
while also getting back to a sense of
normalcy and we have to allow people to
take that control over their lives and
entrust the American people a little bit
to do the right thing because I think
the public is well-educated on the
measures that need to be taken so Dan on
a federal level there's been a lot of
talk about what Congress can do right
now to fill back in for example the the
small business fund the Democrats been
holding that up for no reason that I can
discern what is the status on that is
that gonna pass this week and and how
exactly
well why exactly are Democrats holding
this thing up I mean it's pretty obvious
that this fund needs to be replenished
at this point it's infuriating because
their virtue signalers first and
foremost and they're they're playing the
same kind of games that they've always
played but they they fail to realize
that we're in a crisis and they can't
play those kind of games so what they'll
claim is that fine well we'll we'll
refund the PPP program but we also need
more funding for hospitals and so last
week we were thinking well that money
that we've already designated for
hospitals and for testing for all of
these things that that that's not even
close to running out of money yet but
the PPP program is running out of money
right now why can't you guys just agree
to that
and so now we've waited an entire week
to do that so I think there will be a
deal and it will look like refunding the
PPP program pretty generously which is
which is necessary and then also adding
more money for hospitals and testing
again we never had a problem with this
so this is why this is so infuriating we
never had a problem with that it just
wasn't urgent last week it's not even
urgent now you know it might need to be
refunded so fine I'm happy to do it now
but there was no reason to wait an
entire week no reason at
people have to know this the media lets
the Democrats get away with it they've
gotten away with it three different
times by the way the first time was back
in February again the supposed lost
month of February let me remind
everybody the administration asked for
two and a half billion dollars to fight
the pandemic back on February 24th the
Democrats put anything on the floor no
not even in a few days did they put
something on the floor the only bill
they put on the floor that week was to
ban flavored tobacco would be another
week before we actually better than any
money happen again during the rescue
package which everybody remembers when
Nancy Pelosi wanted like 15 crazy
progressive items added to the list and
eventually we got down to a bill that
looked basically the same as what
already been negotiated but
unnecessarily delayed they're doing the
exact same thing again and they get away
with it time and time again auntie
Pelosi can cool on TV and show everybody
her bazillion dollar fridge and ice
cream and just gets away with it and
then the polling suggests this the
polling shows that the Democrats are
getting away with this I mean so it's
really just up to people like us to get
the truth out there okay so Jen speaking
of sort of when you think that various
states are going to reopen obviously
Texas never really closed down all the
way governor Abbott has already spelled
out some ways in which Texas will reopen
hopefully in the near future what do you
think the timeline looks like for states
like Texas and in terms of getting to
this new normal well by next week we'll
be opening retail but in sort of a
takeout fashion so a lot of retailers
will still be open as they are now it's
it's um you know what's considered the
essential industries but that's still
things like Target Walmart you know
Lowe's Home Depot but more retail will
be allowed open in the future but it'll
be like takeout retail and then we'll
continue to expand on that we've also
allowed much more medical procedures to
take place which is a very good thing
because we're having a dearth of medical
procedures and that that building up and
also people aren't getting the health
care that they need so we're opening
that up as well and I think that stage
transition what will will continue the
important thing to remind people of is
that focusing just on the peak which
which too many policymakers I think talk
about this like well we haven't hit the
peak yet oh okay first of all you have
to look at the absolute value under that
peak and then compare that to your
actual health care capacity people are
forgetting that part of it
people are also forgetting that you
won't really know you hit a peak until
weeks later so you can't you can't
really look into the future and say hey
guys today today was the peak I mean you
can't say that so it's not a useful tool
to it's not the only tool let's say - to
drive public policy and I worry that too
many states are thinking about it that
way with this huge abundance of caution
without thinking of the consequences of
that caution and without comparing their
own actual numbers to their own health
care capacity again New York City should
be making very different policies than
Houston another little thought
experiment I point out to people if
we're so worried about the peak let's do
this let's do a little experiment take
the numbers out of Houston which are
very low cases we've had around 30 low
30s and total deaths in the
fourth-largest city in America took our
numbers and you replaced the word
Houston with New York City you get two
very different policy outcomes New York
City would think oh my god we're we're
well on our way out of this we should
open up we're doing great but in Houston
we're still locked down so it that that
simple that simple thought experiment
shows you that the problem with only
focusing on a peak and the curve that
there's other data that we have to be
thinking about as we make these
decisions well Dan great start it's
representative Dan Crenshaw
representative for Texas second
congressional district go check out his
book fortitude American resilience in
the era of outrage and also his podcast
holds at these fruit stand appreciated
talk to you soon
was great talking event thanks
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content